[Music]
hi jasmine
jasmine where'd you grow up where were
you from originally um well
i was born in inglewood but um
i wasn't born in the hospital and then i
am i end up
being raised in the foster care system
because my mother passed away in 93.
how old were you um i was a baby still
and i ended up living with my
grandmother first
and they ended up taking me at nine for
my grandmother because she was being
abusive and they put me in the foster
care system
um uh from 9 to 18.
but when i was a baby i had already had
a cps worker and all that so
yeah so most of your childhoods yes
foster and jumping around yeah where was
dad
my dad was in and out of prison and he
ended up passing away too as well
how was your childhood with your
grandmother in the foster home
well with my grandmother um
she was abusive um i was always getting
beat and that's what made the worker
come and take me
and remove me from her into actual
foster home with a foster mother
and family and growing up in
the foster home my foster mom she was
the order minister
and she was in the beginning everything
was okay
and whatnot then as i started getting
older um she
started like saying saying like how i
was gonna be a prostitute
how i'm gonna die at an early age how my
own blood family is gonna disown me how
guys are going to beat on me to where
when i graduated high school
and i left from her home i started i
believed it so everything that she said
that was going to happen to me except
death
um has happened like guys beat on me i
became a prostitute because that's all i
wanted when i
when i left um my family disowned me
and i came close to death i got shot by
a client
with a bb gun and so i have bug shots
and broken fragments in my face because
of it but
i it's hard it's very very hard
what age did you start working history
18
fresh out of high school and you worked
with a pimp or on your own um
and when i first got out i had turned
out folks which was a pimp and
it didn't work out with him i started
trying to do the renegade thing
i couldn't do it and then i ended up
meeting
another guy and i was with him for a
long time but it was hard to get away
from him too
so yeah
have you been arrested for this yes i
have too many times
yeah yeah are drugs part of the picture
for you
yes um yes it is
what drugs do you use crystal christmas
i never would have thought
that i would be doing that you get what
i'm saying
right so yeah yeah kids i have four
are you raising them no um i have two
boys and two girls two of them
got taken to the system um because one
of my family members told on me
and then the other two i just had one in
november she's with my sister
and then my one girl is with his dad so
there were family
the last two does doing this for a
living get you down sometimes
it does it really does it's scary
because you never know
whose car you're going to get into like
i said i got shot before not knowing you
know what i'm saying
um it's depressing sometimes
you go through a lot you never know like
i said whose car you're gonna get into
you never know what's gonna happen to
you
it's a lot that comes with the life you
know you've been beaten up and raped
i've been
i've been beaten up i've been raped
before at gunpoint
um came close to death
numerous of times by by the hands of a
pimp and a client it's scary
you know what was your relationship with
tim's like
and like in the beginning it was okay
but then he uses too
and he got to the point to where he
used to choke me to where i'll start
foaming at the mouth
he didn't he beat me his girl stabbed
stab wounds
on my arm my hip and then when i was
pregnant his girl stabbed me right here
when i was pregnant
um i tried to run from him he ended up
finding me
and it just went downhill basically and
it took a lot for me to get away from
him
you know and from by that i end up going
to
where i'm at now and because i don't
have a pimp
and i'm working at someone's hood
basically
um they're taxing me and they see that i
don't have nobody and they don't like
the renegade
thing so one of the guys there he beats
on me he makes me give him money and he
says if i don't he's gonna crack my
skull open
he the other day he stumped me out all
type of stuff you told me last night
recently yeah well just like a couple
days ago he pulled me out of someone's
car
and stuck me out then last night he
stalked me and knocked me out last night
what hours are you typically working
it depends sometimes from like 11 00
in the afternoon and i'll go like be
back and forth and i'll go outside and
i'll be outside to like
maybe one on and off and then i'll go in
when the police gets hot yeah yeah
is it competitive out on the street with
all the girls out there um it used to be
when i used to work the other end of it
like in the 60s because it's a lot of
competition that's why i end up going
down towards imperial because i don't
like to be around a lot of girls because
i feel like that's my competition
when i'm on another end where's not too
many girls i make my money
and it's better for me that way so yeah
when you were
younger did you have dreams of doing
something else with your life medical
system
how far did you go to school um i
graduated high school
and and then i ended up going to
kaplan and i took the you know medical
assisting test to be a medical assistant
to go to school for it i passed it
then i found out i was pregnant with my
kid my first daughter and i never went
back
and what what stops you from doing it
now because you're still young
yeah um how do you know 29 29 yeah you
can still do it
i i can't it's just being in the streets
it will take for me to have to get out
of the area and get away from me get my
mind right i feel like because i don't i
know i have it in me
you know it's just the drugs and i've
been doing this for so long so it's kind
of hard sometimes
you know what was the worst time of your
life
when i got shot in my face wouldn't be
good
um i went on an alcohol
not knowing it was more than one person
in the house
and when i went in there um the guy took
me down the hallway
and when i came to the first room it was
another guy standing by the closet
and something told me to turn around and
run but as soon as i turned around and
run
i heard a lot next thing i'm on the
floor and i feel like a whole bunch of
warm stuff
coming out of my head and couldn't find
out he shot me with a i think the
doctors had a gauge
and they it shot up multiple bug shots
and it sprayed me so i have bug shots
all and broken fragments all in my face
and
i end up he ended up he ended up um they
ended up leaving the two guys
and then my my friend that was outside
heard it came in and they called 9-1-1
and what we were there wasn't no trauma
center
so they had to call the helicopter and
have to airlift me from it was
life california to palm springs regional
and
i almost died because of it but now i'm
stuck with
broken fragments and bug shots still in
my face you could have lost your eyes
right
i could have one one actually missed my
eye right here it's like literally like
right here by my eye
it missed my eye and all through here i
have broken fragments and
a whole bunch of bug shots in my face so
yeah
what was the best time of your life when
i had my kids
kids when i had my kids it just
you know makes me happy but now that
they're not with me kind of
it sucks you know but i know they're
taken care of you know yeah do you ever
talk to them
um no i can't talk to them two of them
i don't know where they're at because i
got adopted out and my last two
um they're too young to to talk
have you been in love before i have
um my
ex folks that i had ran from i was in
love with him but i seen
the things that he was doing to me and
it hurt me and i had it took a lot for
me to
get over that you know because you know
there's no feelings in life there's no
feeling
but i've been loved before and doing
this for a living kind of
makes that difficult right yeah it does
a lot of people don't
a lot of people don't respect working
girls you know
they don't look down on us yeah they
don't realize you have a
heart and soul on the story or what we
go through if they were to put
themselves in our shoes or
sit and ask us like well like
i just talked to us period they always
assume things you know what i'm saying
instead of sitting there and asking a
person or talking to a person they want
to
think this person is like this but not
until you sit and you ask me or
or anything you're not going to know
nothing about me or why i am the way i
am
and that's where people get me twisted
they think i'm a bad person or they
think i'm this i'm that but they never
sit down and ask me or talk to me
to figure out who i really am you know
but yeah
all right jason well thank you so much
for sharing your story good luck with
everything love to see you back with
your kids thanks
you